you say things in a way that is so who
you are and what you believe and yet you
say it in a way that includes everybody
else well I love everybody I always know
that there's that little Godlike that
little thing in every human being and I
try to go to that because I know that
nobody would be the way they are if they
could be different you know it's like I
wrote a song called whatever you are be
that whatever you do do that because
anything else is just an act so whoever
you are be that and I I just I'm not a
good enough person or good enough
Christian to judge and criticize other
people I want to be loved and accepted
so the least I can do is to try to love
and accept other people and I love the
difference in people me too just like
that spice the variety of life being
spice you know I mean if everybody was
the same what you know it would be a
boring life wouldn't
it